what up guys it is Tuesday and that
means it is a great area with myself
Sarah Garvey and the woman who plays
basketball and is currently dunking on
all of her haters it is just plenty
things thank you sir we have a great
show for you today we will be talking
about life after divorce
[Applause]
even get started tell him if you have
watched two or more of our videos and
you have not subscribed then we have
what power beef what do we have beef
exactly so you better get doing that
right now over to you pal okay guys a
couple announcements before we start the
show the first is that we have two clips
channels the first one is called just
pearly clips and the second is called
Pearl daily make sure you go subscribe
to both
um also guys we have four membership
tiers the first one is gonna allow you
to be a part of the live chat tonight
the second is going to allow you to see
our Discord and our behind the scenes
blogs guys I'm getting more active in
the Discord I'm learning how to use it
you could say I'm good at it now so yeah
sign up um it's a little Community
outside of
um the membership tiers third third tier
you get to connect with me on social
media that means having access to my
inbox fourth tier you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month a lot of
people use this if they want to help if
they want to grow on social social media
a lot of people want to know how to put
together a live show
other times people just have questions
about the show so sign up to that if you
want a 30 minute one 30 minute call with
me once a month also guys they banned my
Instagram again not again just like the
the first time oh it's the first time
you've been on Instagram uh-huh oh I
thought you've been before no I was just
I was like um demonetized on Instagram
but yeah they took it away from me
I know they don't like humor I know they
don't like you I know is it the whales
again yeah yeah it was a Wheels again
yeah it was like I mean she called me
ugly so I just pointed out her weight
and but she started it and yet they
still banned me well I guess you stop
you should stop bullying people okay she
pulled me first she was like retaliation
bullying you know what I'm saying like I
don't understand if I if I was just
going after her for no reason well
that's what they make it look like they
say you know you're insecure you know
that's the reason why you're going after
people who hurt you pal who hurt you
nobody hurt me well that's what they say
except that will that attacked me one
time
anyways
um anyways go follow my Instagram just
pearly things one
um because they took away just pearly
things so now I'm on just pearly things
one just probably things one um on top
of that go follow
um my two tick tocks so I'm on just
pearly things dot five but I'm I can't
post on that right now why not
I'm on view only mode
because
you're just you're just unruly on the
internet no I'm not it's unruly I don't
even that one I read a girl you know
what's crazy I read a girl's DM that she
sent to me it was from it was from a
whale but all I did was read what she
sent to me and then I got it and then
you go yeah she was bullying me I'm like
these girls are so kind and considerate
yeah ridiculous now I'm on view only
mode
well anyways just probably thinks top
five but I have a backup which is just
pearly things six so go follow that on
tick tock
um also guys go subscribe to Wife School
we're still editing um we have over a
thousand subscribers which is great uh
but we're still editing the first
episode which is like they basically
um take me
shopping so you should go subscribe to
wife school and
um top Super Chat um all super chats are
going towards blessing getting a monopod
so if you want to see an up in the
production quality of our street
interviews and you want to see me do
Street interviews um please donate for
blessing to get a monopod
that's all I got right that was a long
one yeah right but we um we've actually
got some people here with us today we do
we do
um so we're gonna go around and you guys
can introduce yourselves could you all
introduce yourselves give your name your
age relationship status and a fun fact
about you we'll start over there with
you my dear
with me yes okay okay so my name is
zagner
in the human age I'm 34. I guess you
know it's like um sole age 22.
um certified independent a solid
I understand what she's saying okay so
you feel 22. I feel 22. okay okay you
know I teach 30 that I kind of way stop
teaching in a way where I changed my
life into the different life path you
know
um
so yes lots of things happens give us a
fun fact let's give us a fun fact about
you what's a fun fact
everything is
life you know people look at me it's
like what's wrong with her she always
laughing that's good it is good it's a
good thing so it's a fun fact about me
that you know kind of scares people and
attracts people at the same time
nice yeah all right next
yeah yeah he doesn't look fun
I want smoke today it's a merry
president
I'm a small today
the viewers should know you know hey
follow just um the pre-game podcast show
as well man you know all right next
Lena here I am 20 almost 21.
um
I'm doing fashion
um I'm in a bit of a weird one with the
relationship
um yeah okay yeah what's a weird one
um I guess with like details I like to
be a part of things
what specifics
um we were kind of together for like two
and a half years which is quite would
you say kind of together I mean we
together on and off here and there oh on
and off yeah so now you might be back on
but you're not sure no [ __ ] happened and
he was kind of the one stopping it like
many times and you know a lot of [ __ ]
have happened
um but in the end I've kind of like said
okay I don't think I want anything
anymore I think now we're breaking up
kinda okay and he couldn't take that
because he was always the one you know
kind of felt like he kind of almost had
the power I didn't know what kind of
game he was on but yeah now it's kind of
swapped or changed yeah I don't know I
don't know
so we're now you're rejecting him yeah
and he can't take that oh and now and
now he's mad and it's not like I'm
rejecting him I'm just realizing that
this is not what's good for me and he
could not take that yeah okay yeah okay
who's that in the corner
hey um hey guys it's Jess
um a long time no see on the time I know
it's been a minute she went to America I
did I went home for a bit and now I'm
back
um what was the question you don't get
away with you know you gotta have your
relationship status Jess your age fun
fact I am a 28 in my relationship status
is single and a fun fact is
fun fact
it took me almost I would say 15 minutes
to put a new nose ring in when I first
got it pierced
fair enough yeah that's a fun fact
got you know guys have that poop mix
sometimes I can't find the hotel so I
get it next
um yes my name is Riz uh
28
complicated with the relationship today
yes yeah I was a bit techy
um fun fact about me see uh that's
complicated
see that's that's the issue it's
complicated because so is that do that
because I feel like that means a
situationship
out on all digital platforms
I was alive or not yeah
um
complicated
um
yeah fun fact I don't I don't really
know like a fun fact about myself but
I'm into anime that's fun it's a fact
okay this is your favorite anime oh IEC
because like bleach is officially back
like anime I read the mango so when it
finished my heart was broken it was done
they stopped the anime halfway through
and I was like you now they bought it
back my all-time favorite anime it has
to be bleached yeah and you know what
you know what I saw on bleach like tell
me if tell me if this if I missed this
saying up here but it was so relevant to
like this whole thing my mom was like yo
War doesn't happen unless two sides have
a valid reason for fighting and you know
you just don't think about that until
like you actually deep it it's like oh
yeah like they wouldn't be who is evil
because both sides are actually fighting
for what they think is rajas
yeah you guys lost me with it I don't
know about it anything about anime I
don't know nothing about it no forget
the anime I just I just got that saying
from it like you know I mean I don't
really watch Bleach but
you know what I mean Jess someone in the
chat says Jess has a man in Northern
California if she wants one
just so you know just DM me
right folks let's get to the subject
today we're talking about life after
divorce so I'm gonna ask a question
is it fair
that a woman can cheat on a man
take his house
take his cause take his children and
then dictate to that man when and where
he can see or cannot see his children is
that a fair system no
oh I don't I don't think so if she if
she did the cheating she has no room to
say nothing
and if she did the cheating and she left
she chose she chose to cheat and she
chose to leave so why would you as
you're not gonna get a prize for losing
essentially and it's like you can't
dictate what someone does when you
you chose
but they do get rewarded don't they they
do unfortunately seems like a super Fair
system just so fair so fair ladies is
that fair system
acne
it was a very personal kind of thing you
know it's like again like it's a
materialistic thing so when we're
looking from this perspective what do we
have even in life you know it's not in
kawas and we're not really own anything
you know
in this situation I don't know what
happened between them two like she
cheated clearly maybe man was like super
awesome man and he was like super
awesome man then it's sad for the man
that it happened to him you know but
then again like you know everybody kind
of plays some certain part even that
cheating happened why did it happen well
at four still it didn't force or
whatever with that man they didn't give
whatever she wanted actually he had the
house he had money had everything
enough you know but then again that's a
different map and it's a personal you
know
but regardless of what happened do you
think he deserves to I don't think
anybody deserves to be out cheated out
treated or out done any kind of way you
know
so now I don't think so
what'd you think
um
she just wanted the house she wanted the
kids she wanted everything for herself
she didn't want any man anymore
basically
it's like a cheat code crazy yeah it's
crazy but that's the system we currently
live on we currently live under whereas
um a woman can actually do all of that
and still be rewarded for it
sorry to worry about that this was like
proof like they went to court or
something yeah like yeah gone to court
you know he can she can take his
finances she can take his children she
can take his house wait hold on pause
I'm I'm pretty sure if she cheats no
um right now in the UK there's something
called no fault divorce have you ever no
fault division so no fault diverse
divorce means somebody can um they can
apply or apply for a divorce
and it can be quote unquote no one's
fault wow
um historic historically women have
always had the upper hand in being award
to awarded child custody statistics show
that women win child custody rights
staggeringly 90 of the time yeah so yeah
you can cheat and then do no fault
divorce and say it's no one's fault and
you can supply for a divorce and it can
be no one's fault and you can still get
all of that stuff
do you know do you know what I'm
thinking about yeah
no not even that yeah forget that you
know if you look at it the other way
around like would if he was in a
marriage year and you got divorced and
the court gave you the the kids
would you even like want to take it or
like
um yeah because at the end of the day
she violated me and you're leaving our
situation and the fact that I'm not the
type of person to go to court so if we
go to court it was because of her so if
I won of course yeah I'm gonna take all
of that no so you're saying so you're
saying the woman's right to take it then
no [ __ ] right not just the one that did
the cheat and you can't leave if I'd
done a cheating then you know what by
all means it is I messed up right it
doesn't matter who cheated
huh it doesn't matter who cheated how do
you mean because if the man cheated and
she she leaves she could leave if she
cheated she could leave but it doesn't
matter and seeing the marriage it's not
even just that same the fact that one
cheats and then the other one leaves
you're breaking up the home
so regardless
yeah but if you're breaking up the home
should you be the one that's getting
everything
no fairness no I said I don't believe so
but what if the
it's a It's like a
a weird situation if the Man Cheats but
he has everything is he supposed to give
everything to the woman because he
cheats and he decides to leave and
that's all yeah that's his his well a
lot of the time even when the man cheats
he still gets a lot of his stuff taken
away anyway so like he gets well and
what they don't talk about is that one
in four marriages are sexless so it's
like if you're yeah one in four so if
you're if you're starving your man of
sex and he goes and gets it elsewhere
that's your own damn fault I swear to
God I don't feel bad for you if you get
cheated on him no that's an agenda if
you're not if you're not sleeping with
your husband and and he cheats on you
like that is your own goddamn fault I
swear to God some other girl says you
know what I'm gonna do it she's not but
yeah
no but what's the um
what's the like price like in terms of
like the types of people that are
getting married so like like in terms of
their the monies that they make
like oh is it generally you mean yeah
like in like statistically like would it
be more um I think rich people get
married right because rich people right
so if we're talking about rich people
afford a wedding exactly boom so if the
girls the girls should be working anyway
she's independent so
assuming she's independent right you
know we live in the equal Society right
now she should be working as well
do we live in an equal Society
assuming we live in an equal Society
yeah yeah
but inverted commas you know
I'm just saying the way that is
structured right now
she's supposed to be working
so if she's working and she leaves
how are you going to be able to say the
same thing that you were saying back in
the day before like because you're gonna
say so her excuse for taking the kids
before was oh he's working all the time
he's not gonna have time to look after
the kids but she's working now so she
has to work double time now just to make
it well when it comes to come on
um I looked up the reasons that women
and men file for a divorce
um and one and this is and there's some
articles that are it's kind of like I'm
not sure like some of them kind of
switch but one is a couple stopped
loving you this is for women the couple
stopped loving each other does that
sound more like women or men
um being bad with money yeah
um the other party having personal
problems lack of love and affection for
men the top four is infidelity lack of
appreciation lack of affection and lack
of commitment that's what it says and we
already know that in the UK 64 of
um divorces are initiated by women in
the U.S since 17 64 in the US is 70 to
even 90 if you're College if you're a
college college educated no but I'm
saying that that's bringing back to my
point so I'm saying then since the
incentivize to do it yeah so can you
really blame someone for being sensitive
like if you told me just marry this girl
and in a year's time you could just
divorce her and take all everything
she's uh take all her things and then
the system's done for you to do that I
would go and do it do you know what I
mean so I don't think that
you know if you told me there's a
million pounds inside of the the truck
I'm gonna go get you know I mean it's
like giving me a reason I mean I blame
you if you care more about finances than
your children if you want to put your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
you could ever put a kid at just for a
bag man or a woman I judge you for that
no but that's selfish no no you're
missing the point these single single
mothers are not single what do you mean
they got man bro they have this I was
gonna say that you see when women
initiate divorces do you think their
initiating divorces to be alone
one thing about God they always have a
backup so if she's she's in a whole
marriage you're leaving to go to where
you already had your pillow you're not
the type of person that obviously can
can support without a pillow so where's
your next pillar comment even if it
comes every now and then you need that
pillow which means you add someone on
the side you're back Upland and what
tends to happen as well is those sidemen
don't really want a wife you like how
your husband was wiping you so now like
after the little fling happened and you
get bored now and like it's not going as
how it should be you're now thinking in
your head where I'm I'm alone now so
that's that's the single moment yeah
yeah you you made some incorrect
decisions you know what's interesting um
men are more likely to say that they
want to get married again than women why
do you think that is
um I think that's because men want a
legacy they they want a legacy to show I
think men I can speak for my own
personal experience there is a
there's a pride in men when people say
oh if you've got partner yet this is my
wife this is my children look what I've
done look at look at my legacy look at
my kingdom there's that um there's that
pride in men more so I think that there
is in in the modern day women nowadays
that's what I think also there's a lot
of Sims
I understand there's like there's a lot
of guys like that's their way to lock
down a girl
did you get
to offer marriage yeah that's like
that's the only way I can keep her to
lock her down oh man I have to marry her
would you get married
but that's religiously he said he's
gonna have multiple wives
That's religiously you know what I'm
saying like I want to be in heaven with
my wife isn't it
so so
given the current system that I said
like you would get married under this
marriage system
knowing that you could lose everything I
want to lose everything I said knowing
that you could lose everything I could I
couldn't lose everything every man could
deny it's impossible really why because
I'll I'll have more than one
yeah
no but imagine both of them divorce you
and take me your money okay then there
will be another lineup you know I'm
saying we make money over here at me so
it take off and then let's see what you
do have you ever heard stories about
what people when they got the lottery do
the money bro
you give some of these girls a million
pounds and they'll go broke in a year
man come on bro let's get real now yeah
but that's easy to say now when you're
young I mean imagine you get divorced at
60. oh a lot of guys commit suicide
after divorce because they have to start
over and they have no energy to do it
men are five times more likely after a
divorce to commit suicide than women are
there was an actor
um R.I.P Red Ranger he was a power
ranger and green is a green ranger
wasn't it he was originally the Red
Ranger
[Music]
you're right you're right was he
originally the Green Ranger and then he
came in as a white ranger then he became
the Red Ranger and then for Wild Force
he was also the Red Ranger and then for
the Dino Thunder he was black Ranger
sorry all right one piece
um so he he recently
um he either got divorced or his wife
was going to leave him no I think he did
get divorced and then he ended up
committing suicide
that's why because yeah his wife cheated
I don't know if his wife cheated but
divorced him like divorce really affects
men you know I think people kind of
downplay don't really understand how
divorce really does affect men
like men take breakups like way worse
than women do I believe I I know men
that have that are in mental
institutions because of a breakup yeah
but where did they get married though
what you mean where because
depends where and when you got married
depend like hey people not in the no no
you know
where what does it mean
well I mean okay okay this one for the
people I forget some people don't know
and this is not for the one percent that
don't understand nothing I take things
out of context here just get off the
internet listen so in England polygamy
is illegal
yes to have multiple wires in England is
illegal but please believe there's men
in England with multiple wives those men
everywhere with multiple wives sometimes
they just don't even know about each
other
you can have one in Birmingham
[ __ ] I'm way on business can I answer
ladies here would you get married or are
you married
I was married yes separated
for the last two years near the tree
went nicely we went
ways
um yeah amazing man amazing awesome
awesome okay did you did you initiate
divorce uh I did yes because I fall in
love with somebody else and I knew
there's nothing that we can work on
anymore and that's my part is something
wait a minute wait a minute
so hang on you said you're so so you've
got you had an amazing man yeah and what
you had you had an affair no but you
found someone else I didn't found it
just it happened you know nothing just
happened well there you go everything
happens for the reason so that was must
be a reason where was he so like how did
you meet the other guy uh so we moved in
Canada
and that was like I think after six
months later
well no I'm saying like you had to meet
him somehow
like at work yeah yeah yeah you met so
you met another guy at work yeah and
then you fell in love with the other guy
yeah but you didn't cheat you're saying
it was like an emotional thing yeah and
then you realized you're in love with
him yeah and did you are you still with
the other guy I know
guys
so how how long were you with the second
guy uh for two years two years
um looking back was it worth it uh of
course
we have to learn from our own lessons
and our own mistakes you know so even
like getting married I love the man you
know and I always gonna love him did you
have children with the with your husband
no I didn't no that sounds toxic way
do you mean I just explained that like
five minutes ago that same similar
scenario but like that's your life
approach you know that's how you live
your life so everybody like we're all
unique we're all different do you think
that was do you think that was selfish
after you made vows like you made vows
that you're going to be with this guy
for the rest of your life blah blah blah
do you think it was selfish what you've
done uh
really yeah no do you think it was a
mistake uh no
so if you're you're single now uh yes so
if you stayed single the rest of your
life would it be a mistake then
um probably not because I'm quite happy
with myself so you feel contempt with
how everything's going on so far yeah
absolutely
if I was I'm speaking from like my
perspective I was in your position I'd
be like dang I should have just stay
with my husband I would be I don't know
because I wanna I want to get married I
want to like have a family have kids and
just be able to like do the things that
I've done with my family do it with my
kids and my husband and so
if I was in that position and like
nothing after the divorce worked out and
I was like I left my husband for this
I'm not saying this to like make you
feel bad anyway I'm just saying it from
my perspective I was it
um I would just I'd be distraught I'd be
running please I'd be like please
if you don't mind me asking how did he
deal with the divorce when you came to
him and you said I want a divorce so I
found somebody else how did he deal with
that he was super supportive super
supportive yeah it's like it's so so
pity because he's like even before we
got married because like I had this
feeling that that we even like meant to
be together in case that even back then
I already thought about divorce you know
and then he's like I never said anything
so I thought we're gonna work through it
and then at the end of the day it still
came to that day that now you actually
want to get divorced so he's like it's
kind of mutual feeling but at the same
time it's like so sad that you know we
like we're planning so many different
things and we were so good together you
know I used to do still like are you
still friends or well we kind the
friends but we don't talk anymore at all
do you think love is a feeling or a
choice
I think it's a feeling for sure his
energy and there's always the you know
always energy surrounding so then don't
you do you would you want to get married
again
I do I do and I do believe that like we
all have like our proper person to each
other how long do you want to be married
wait wait how long do you want to be
married
how long so if you got married again how
long do you again like it's not even
about the marriage I just want to have
that person you know to spend like The
Eternity with you know it's not even a
lifetime anymore you know yeah so after
filming the experience I just want to
explain how men like hear what you're
saying so when when men hear this and I
think as a woman like we understand what
you're saying a little better but when
men hear this it's like a red flag
because that means you're gonna go if
you're just not feeling it it is
multiple red flags as a man listening to
your story yeah I'm sitting there
thinking
you ain't just gonna marry me and just
be like oh well I felt this way and I'm
gonna leave and there's no way I if I
heard that story as a man I'm like that
I ain't getting married to you I think
what's exactly and that's the point for
life that I never go to anybody or
everybody even if I go to somebody
that's always thought about it it's
always has to be like something so in my
life there's in general there's like you
know uh listen I'm not saying you should
be someone that you don't want to be
with but like I want to know how do you
love someone
without first liking them
[Music]
so did you fall out of like with him you
just didn't like him no no no no no no
no because you left my man for for the
other guy so I'm saying how do you love
my other guy
without liking him first
so of course you like the person
huh right like I don't really get it
though okay so the guy at work did you
like him first before you you loved him
I think so
that's what I'm saying so yeah wasn't
there like a point in that time when
this is what pissed me off bro
so what he's asking is that was there a
point where it came like you liked him
what was the point where you started to
like have feelings fall in love with him
because I'm just thinking like I've had
co-workers before but you'd have to
spend a bunch of time with him outside
of work to fall in love and isn't that
kind of like inappropriate you know I
mean like I'm just thinking if I was in
a marriage and then my co-worker asked
me to hang out outside of work
yeah and we didn't hang out after work
so and then that was like after like a
month maybe kind of period the thing is
you said that you didn't
um have an affair you said it was kind
of an emotional thing
um it's very hard to believe for a man
that a woman would file for divorce
um
and there's been no sexual contact with
this guy you know I mean it's it's very
hard for a man to hear it would be hard
to believe oh it was just an emotional
thing no we don't we I wouldn't believe
it because they're like in my case it
was it doesn't matter even if I gonna be
with this new guy or not I still gonna
be read on my own and like set
everything clear now and let another
person go to to move on with his own
life it's like if we're gonna continue
working and working it's like yes we can
reach that point where we can actually
like learn to love each other again in
the way like with maybe passion way or
some kind of different way but again you
know that that's not the person you want
to be with because and you know that he
knew already that's the point it was
that it was mutual agreement I think
we're sold a dream as women because like
you only get passionate love for like
two three years maybe that's what my dad
always told maybe she's looking two
three my dad said at most two three
years yeah and so what do you think of
it six months no I'm saying I'm like
only two three years yeah that's it sure
yeah
lifetime let's go yeah but that's the
thing because you know mother women have
been raised on rom-coms and and Disney
movies and so you guys think that you
know life is a Disney movie and a
rom-com and it's like no it's actually
no you're in a 10-year relationship how
long would you say that the honeymoon
phase the honeymoon when does it go into
a more
three and three and a half years maybe
like can we switch it after three four
years it's like okay now we're just
we're coasting in this yeah we're in
this groove do you know what I mean and
so there are dips and there are like you
know apexes and the dips and then apexes
and then coasting but yeah that that I
want to see you every day and have sex
with you five times a day type love does
not last
it just doesn't it does
where show me it now if you have four
wives
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday your
whole life is a honeymoon phase AJ me
and me and just around the market sister
wow
but we're getting closer
yeah no I just didn't care that that
whole um and I think that's the reason
why women are the ones initiating
divorces because they get into
relationships and they realize hang on a
minute this is actually work this isn't
what they showed me in a Disney movie
This is actually what they showed me in
a rom-com I've actually got work at this
like you know I've got to wake up this
person's farting in the bed and you know
I mean like all of this kind of stuff
they're burping and all of a sudden the
way they chew food annoys you you know
what I mean it's like it's a whole thing
so it's like yeah I think relation I
think men are actually better at dealing
with just being in a Groove in a
relationship than women are I think
women lack a little bit of chaos they're
like a little bit more Spicer like
something to
um make them a little bit more excited
whereas men are actually cool with just
being in the groove what do you guys
think of the phrase
if you want I can't remember exactly how
it's phrased but it's like
the worst thing you can do to a woman a
woman is bore her
as a man what do you think of that
that's a bit mad still I was afraid the
worst thing you could do to women it
might not be the worst it's just like if
you want her to leave like I can't
remember how they phrased it but it was
something
her to leave
basically was what they were trying to
say
that much stuff I mean in a relationship
like you both kind of get bored a little
bit but like I don't know that's a bit
rude I don't know it's a bit mad star
but that's the thing I think women like
chaos essentially I think women like
chaos I think they like to not know
what's going on they say they want
stability but when women get stability
they stop violent filing for divorces
it's boring it's like they want you to
they want something more exciting than
this to vanilla yeah it's too vanilla
hmm But actually I have a I have a
question for the girls okay would you
rather date
a musician or a
an accountant
she's dated a musician before
you did so you pick musicians
yeah musician okay what about you
um probably the musician as well yeah
what about you Jess I love music so I
would date the musician my watch this
see the musician
obviously I could go for the account but
I I love music so like I think it would
be not saying I'd be born with the
Conchas account because love music was
this like a musician no see but it
improves my point yeah like women don't
want stability like that well that's the
most unstable job you could possibly
have that's music but we all pick music
I actually watched a tick tock video um
recently with a woman she was on you
know she was speaking to this other guy
and he was like why did you file for
divorce and she was like oh he
he was really good with money and you
know he would save and
um it just it was like he didn't really
want to spend and it's like so he was
the guy was like so he was financially
stable and he was you know good with
money and that's what really pissed you
off she was like yeah he didn't really
want to do anything with the money and
he was always saying we need to save for
a rainy day and I was just like
we can't win bro that's the dumbest
thing I've ever like we can't win like
because he couldn't because he saved too
much because that probably didn't spend
on what she wanted she wanted him to
spend on the buffoonery that doesn't
help bring in the income yeah I have a
question would you guys go
um so who is their nails done here for
you yeah okay three okay okay
um do any of you get like your makeup
done or anything like lash lifts any of
that
no no no no no okay would you guys go
down in lifestyle so no new clothes no
nails done nothing like that
um so like in a year you might get a
couple new outfits that's it for a
family and you'd have to work twice as
hard and
um
make
like no extra like you'd get no extra
discretional income
for a family would you yes or no oh yeah
yeah of course like I did that for three
years
continuing still now and then I did the
13 years helping family too okay good
good what about you
you go down on lifestyle for a family
yeah yeah
you
I don't know how much lower my lifestyle
can get but
my lifestyle is pretty like yeah it is
neutral so yeah I would go down in it I
don't need my nails done do you women
think that it's I talking about divorce
you think it's better for women than it
is for men after divorce
women
is it you're saying do you think it's
better yeah I do think it's better
because I'm I'm gonna read you some some
divorce settlements right so Melinda
gatesman here and Bill Gates
um divorced she got she's now worth 6.7
billion
Mackenzie Scott who is uh Jeff beards
his ex-wife she's now worth 27.9 billion
Nicole young he was Dr Dre's
um ex-wife she's now worth 100 million
so women get
a lot of money from these divorces and
men get to kind of see their empire
slashed in half and crumble I don't know
I guess there is kind of like a little
bit of like an after rush after being in
a relationship for a long time and you
get out of it whether you know it was
you or the other person stopping it that
is just like this thing where you were
low for
however long your low forward but then
at one point when you get out of that
you do feel almost like new kind of
again I don't know it's just like
it obviously depends on how close you
are with the person but resemble me
recently I felt better also because the
relationship was really toxic but I feel
better getting out of it you know after
going through like that part where it
was hurting
it's like yeah I felt like almost like
reborn really yeah
I don't know but maybe it does relates
to like women getting out of you know
this kind of relationship maybe feeling
trapped or maybe they don't love the
person anymore for whatever reason you
know
[Music]
it's because women think of relationship
of marriage like relationships
it's like even when you look at
relationships
girlfriends are more likely to leave
anyway
yeah like yeah yeah same as with
divorces yeah yeah the condition to like
just leave like you know I mean like if
the going gets tough just leave
do you think guys always been like that
or do you think that is well no this is
the society nowadays it portrays like oh
if he ain't if he ain't doing what you
want him to do
go get your bag do this do everything
for yourself because I I just said I
think hypergamous I think hypergamy has
always been a thing but I think
hypergamy is currently on steroids I
think the monkey brought chin is like a
woman like right now
any woman hair I probably can go into
your DMs right now and there's a guy in
there trying it
training women have always got guys
trying to shoot their shot Jess you just
had a guy say if you want to go if you
want a man right you got a man in what
North Carolina or something was it Pearl
did you know I think California Northern
California like women have always got
guys throwing themselves at them do you
know what I mean and so yeah that whole
oh if he's not doing it I've got someone
else in Northern California now that
will do it for me do you know what I'm
saying so women have always got a guy in
the background somewhere there's always
someone slipping around your vagina yeah
but you as a man you're potentially like
two two weeks away
from what from a divorce or a breakup no
if I'm getting back on your team
if you really think about it
you get the first little day or two to
get over it and cry River or whatever
yeah dude don't do it in front of her no
like the inside the doors or whatever
get over it and then start chips and
again
bounce back you know what I'm saying
when you bounce back you start chirpsing
again rule of ten you know you Chuck's
100 you get 10 numbers
cool 10 phones you get one then he
starts pressurizing getting back on you
know what I'm saying
they get back come on I just I just want
to read something um I looked I was
trying to look up the divorce numbers
um from like 100 years ago
um and this is just in the 1900s if you
wanted a divorce in the early 1900s you
had to prove your significant other had
committed adultery abused or abandoned
you in 1903 the inner Church conference
on marriage and divorce was held to
encourage many churches to prohibit
divorce and to call for stricter
Nationwide divorce laws that would only
allow divorce if infidelity could be
proven
but the Women's Conference in Seneca
Falls in 1848 had made a huge and
lasting impact feminism had been gaining
ground for more than 50 years and with
it more women were deciding they weren't
willing to stick around in abusive or
unhappy relationships the threat of
divorce even promoted Theodore Roosevelt
to give states with lacks divorce laws
of verbal bashing in this 1906 annual
message
but basically the point is a lot harder
to get divorced back then well so it was
yeah yeah well with no fault divorce
right now you can you can literally be
married to a woman come home one day and
she can just be like I want a divorce
and you're like why 1915 one in seven
marriages still ended in divorce sorry
sorry I'm sorry say that again in 1915
if this is correct one in seven
marriages still ended in divorce one in
seven yeah one in seven I mean that's
way lower than today but it's still
higher than I thought it would be in
1910.
1920 is 15
um 1930s was the Great Depression so
more couples got married it seems like
um I don't see an actual percentage here
but it's they said divorce like marriage
went up in the Great Depression yeah
why go ahead yeah and if that's the four
years old World War II here's a stack
um one year after divorce
40 of men
lose contact with their children
um
um after two after two years it can go
up to 60 of men lose contact with their
children now a lot of things a lot A lot
has been said about quote unquote
deadbeat dads right but men that choose
to marry women and have children with
them don't seem like deadbeat dads to me
from the outside so why would you guys
say
that so many men within a year of being
divorced lose contact with their
children I think women are spiteful they
can be yeah I think men are much more
willing to like take the L and move on
where women like if she feels like you
did her wrong they just become spiteful
also as a man you feel like you don't
want to um
interfere with what she's got going on
what do you mean because okay so she's
left you for another another guy yeah
you're you don't want to be in the
entanglement you get me no but it's your
children no yeah but the longer yeah you
know taking into account that now she's
with her next man she has another baby
father well now she you know what I'm
saying now she's in a
a happy marriage now or another happy
relationship now anything from the past
becomes irrelevant and she tries to make
that the new Hall so the original daddy
somehow get pushed to the side
why didn't I give men more incentive to
want to be with your kids because like
that's the most likely person to abuse
them isn't it right yeah exactly no but
not not necessarily because
you think about it this way you'll
you'll be interfering with what they got
going on in a sense
you'll be disrupting their routine
you'll be like like if if you're already
in a combative relationship there's
going to be arguments there's going to
be unnecessary stuff that's going on
you're already feeding the child certain
things in the child's head obviously
sorry but it really depends on
what she's like you know what I mean
that's what I'm saying yeah so that's
like so okay I'm not saying that the um
the goat
um mothers are the number one
perpetrators of abuse I did not know
that wow number the number one followed
that's crazy it followed by fathers or
step parents it's not seen as abuses I
mean on on my YouTube channel I did an
interview with a guy called Mr ibiley
Right and I wanted to tell his story
because I knew his story and he'd spent
upwards of 25
000 pounds trying to see his um child
and he had got like video recordings
audio recordings of the mother you know
after they broke it up and the kinds of
things that she was saying the kind of
things that she was doing and I think
one of the things that aren't spoken
about when you look at that stat is that
like pal said yeah women can be very
spiteful when it comes to children
because I know as a father myself most
people know that the one thing that a
man is going to be attached to is his
child do you know what I mean and so a
lot of the time women tend to use that
child as a pawn in a game and I think a
lot of men get to the point where they
just say you know what I'm not I'm not
doing this you know and it seems like
they are quote unquote deadbeat dads but
it's not it's just that they're not
willing to jump through all the Hoops
that the woman's actually put in front
of them to jump through it's like a
control game yeah you don't want to go
along with the system
yeah I think it's one of the things that
aren't spoken about enough personally
when it comes to men I mean I do
consultations with men each week and um
these are some of the things that come
up you know some of the men are saying
look my ex-wife ex-partner is using the
child we used to be able to co-parent
now she can
tell me when and when I can't or can see
the child I just think it's and women
have too much power in this Society
right now especially when it comes to
breakups
it's devastating it's really bad on the
kids and I I think that some mothers
don't
realize that like these good Fathers
that they're robbing like time from for
their kids to see them and then they
curate this whole idea like whatever you
and him had it doesn't is nothing to do
with the kids that's y'all relationship
you shouldn't rob a child of their
relationship with their father no matter
what has happened between the mother and
the dad and that stuff if it's not dealt
with as a child it manifests into stuff
as an adult and then you have your grown
kids
asking like oh well like why did this
and this happen with Dad why didn't I
get to see him growing up and it's not
like oh he did this to you he did that
to you it's like oh he did this to me he
did that to me so I decided that he
wasn't uh worthy enough to see you and
it's like whatever you and that man have
you figured that out do not bring the
kids into it and Rob them of that chance
to have a father that's what happened to
Kanye I mean when he got older he found
out his um his mother that he like
adored yeah wasn't letting him see his
father and like left
um where his father was and moved to
Chicago yeah
um and I honestly think that should be a
crime well I think that should be occur
if you if you keep your your baby father
from your kids I think that you should
be charged with something because you're
putting your kid at everything yeah yeah
you're you're putting your kid at every
statistical
disadvantage for what is that is that a
hyperbole or is that like an actual
flagpole well I'll tell you the facts
ninety percent of single parent homes
are headed by women 90 right 63 of Youth
suicides are from single mother homes
ninety percent of homelessness and
runaway children are from single mother
homes 71 of high school dropouts are
from single mother home 70 of youths in
operated institutions are from single
mobile homes 80 of all youths in prison
are from single mother homes 85 of
children who show behavioral disorders
are from single mother homes eighty
percent of rapists with anger problems
are from where single mother homes so
like spell says you're putting your
child at every every statistical
disadvantage when you choose to just be
a quote-unquote single mother and I
think if you leave the Dad should get
the kids if you choose to leave I'm
sorry you don't get rewarded and then
you know it's the worst thing when
they'll be like oh I have to watch the
kids okay give them to him then
um like the girls will always say oh I
had to watch the kids I'm like what do
you mean you get to spend time with your
children that's not a that's a good
thing give them to him that no but I
swear the system is like if the if the
male has the child for a certain amount
of time then it's co-parenting so they
don't get any money well I can have a
little bit anecdotal story here right
um when I broke up with my son's mom
I didn't realize that when you co-parent
in this country when you actually
co-parent meaning you do 50 50 nobody
owes each other any money yeah I didn't
know that so I was giving like money
each month and all this kind of stuff
did she know that
please assume she did I don't know I
don't know and then then I read it
somebody said it to me and I read it and
I was like oh oh snap what am I giving
you money for I'm like yeah it's true I
don't have to give you no dough and
that's when the problem started
they've been told this from time like yo
make sure you
um no don't allow him too many days you
get me because yeah yeah because they're
yeah you're paid you're paid you're paid
you're given more money if you don't let
him see the kids so like women are
incentivized to not let you see the
children yeah and it's not like people
always get on me and say like I'm harsh
on women I'm like I I think men if they
were paid to do bad things they would
also do bad things but women are paid
for bad decisions of course
there was a um
a couple from America they're on Love
and Hip Hop can't remember which one but
Safari I think with Safari and his now
Erica yep there you go
um they got divorced and I don't know
the ramification of the divorce nothing
but then she got word of how much she
was receiving in child support and it
was around like was it I think it was
like six thousand four thousand four
thousand and she was upset about that
like
what is a child that's four thousand
dollars a child can live on that until
they're
18 four thousand dollars whatever every
month every month every month like I'm
like okay thanks four thousand dollars
cool but she was upset that it was so
little little and she was like I went
through this I went through that just to
get four thousand dollars I'm like you
could get nothing like four thousand
dollars is a lot what do you do you need
it for you or do you need for your child
if you just need it for your child
you're straight because you apparently
have what you need for you and she'd go
around saying oh he's a deadbeat he
doesn't give enough money but do you why
did you stop the story there why didn't
you continue it so I found out that she
she co-parents with him oh see I didn't
know that yeah they co-parent oh really
and he still gives her money I don't
think that's a law in the states though
the same is here I think no no I'm
saying he drops a p like wait so how no
because that was a court decision but he
said on his Instagram that my co-parent
yeah I don't I don't think it matters in
the states like if you co-parent or not
you still have to pay child support if
they take you I don't know what I'm
saying if I if I have the child for free
free days of the week that 4 000 you're
still thinking the 4000 is like okay get
me for the whole month you know it's
just for free days in the week that you
got him yeah well four days like half
the month yeah it's like half the month
like 15 days
yeah it's like how how much money does a
parent need I mean I know that when my
son's with me half the week I'm the one
clothing him I'm the one feeding him
he's he's using electricity that I pay
for you know what that I pay for it's
one of those things that men have kind
of been conditioned to think oh you're
supposed to give the mother of your
child money each month because she would
be the one struggling and it's like well
I might be struggling too like I've got
I've got the child here too you know
what I mean like what he's he's giving
me money and women want equality until
it doesn't benefit until it doesn't
benefit yeah and that's that's the thing
like we want it to be equal be equal
what the [ __ ] like you have a job to get
baby mama should get a job are we
addressing the elephant in the room
which is what huh
okay let me let me address it let me
address a little bit of it you get me
because it seems like Pearl don't want
to address it I'll address it
first and foremost yeah if you want to
clip this you can clip this and send
this wherever you want to send this bro
just pearly things yeah just pearly
things is a network yeah so when you
when you tag just pearly things just
know you're coming for everyone on the
on the show with all our views combined
yeah
so I'll start with that secondly Abba
and preach here these guys oh my God
all right this is left the field by
going okay so first of all yeah this is
the elephant in there yeah this is this
is the elephant in the room because you
know what they're doing they've gone
around here and my man has basically
said you're misogynistic
bro I met a man called a woman
misogynistic because she could she
because you know what I'm trying to say
and uh when they say you gotta say
divorce but keep going bro no no no no
no no no we're going we're gonna get
them we're gonna get them listen you've
sat down and you've ate off just pearly
things by tagging us yeah and your
production is not our production our
production is Big out here you get me we
do we have guests coming in we have big
sets Ox blessing you know I'm saying we
have stuff we go we go we go outside we
put people in in black people's pockets
yeah so for two guys from wherever you
look from because it's not from Haiti
because if it was from Haiti you would
have spoke about it yeah you would have
spoke about what's going on in Haiti but
it don't sound like that sound like
you're from upside so listen let me say
turn into YouTube guys here do not
mention just pearly things again yeah
otherwise it'll be more smoke bro I've
got bear smoke for you like bro both of
you look I got smoke for Abba and Peach
bro
preach a little bit less but I got smoke
for you bro po how old are you
uh I just turned 26. all right Paul just
turned 26. you lot of big men yeah and
I've heard you say on your pod on your
little review thing here you sit on your
own review thing
when I was younger I used to do dinner
no no no no no no you a big man trying
to tell a good Pro we've got smoke for
you lot bro please don't mention it
um when you say that don't say we just
say you got smoke because that's what I
said I I said that's why I said I got
smoke for these guys
I got smoke for them because they didn't
just say Pro they said just pearly
things they quoted it so now you're
talking about the whole network
these manners did the reviews in front
of a camera and an iPhone don't don't
try it bro don't compare what Pearl does
to what you look do come on people come
on the show and they could tell their
views all day every day and no one
stopped them Pearl gives them equal time
to talk so eat this is good it goes out
to even girls out there that try to talk
crap and follow this misogynistic crap
you don't know what misogynistic means
bro you're under the misantry stuff here
that's what you look do bro I'll light
up the internet bro I'll light them up
bro listen you little spreading rumors
and lies and clipping things don't watch
that girls come on here every single day
when we've got shows on and talk Madness
the most Madness and expect not to get
Clips bro you look we get Clips if you
talk Madness bro you would if you talk
Madness you get clipped if you want to
come on the show and talk sense but how
many girls have you seen come on here
with like a notepad with notes or
something about feminism and that
um maybe what does that count maybe two
one two
it's all right what about you maybe one
they always say I feel like I feel like
I feel like they don't come here with
facts to debate and have good
discussions and and move the the
consensus on bro just waste Cadets bro
stay at home on Tick Tock and keep
banging people and do what you do bro go
to your nine to five and don't try to
succeed at nothing bro and die alone
with your cats and dogs no one cares do
you you do you boo-boo but don't try
tell us we can't discuss it among people
that want to discuss it yeah stay off
just pearly things bro please
we got smoke bro
right that was so left to filled bro but
no because I'm glad you got it off your
chest how the hell was that the elephant
how was that an elephant in the room
brother I'll tell you why because oh my
God
we were talking about divorce I'm like I
don't even know where he's going
he's going not because you were saying
you were saying things about because
okay in the video they was I'll address
what they were saying he's still going
he still got no dress what they were
saying in the video they're saying Pearl
is misogynistic because she thinks that
women should not vote yeah but she said
that in tongue-in-cheek yeah to bring up
the the the the debate which you are
having
yeah and you said quote your words it's
like saying a black man saying we should
bring back slavery I'm saying that now
we should bring back slavery because
I'll tell you why since Haiti fought for
their their freedom the first to do it
calm down well no I'm just being
tongue-in-cheek I'm not involved here
yeah yeah I'm being I'm being
tongue-in-cheek I'm saying don't bring
back slavery please don't you see that's
that's the problem we got with the
internet there's the one percent people
that's dictate into 99 about how the
English language should be used like we
don't understand context we don't
understand nuances we don't understand
debate so when they try to to to to try
to shift the goal posts and make straw
man arguments we're not having it bro we
have debates on just pearly things on
the gray area on on um King Richard's
show on on
antigenous show it's not just one little
two guys sitting down in front of a
camera do not come for smoke I'll come
for you guys
intellectually though because you've got
some bad issues that you're not need to
sort out both of you
well well
um
divorce let me get back to divorce guys
um as a matter of fact that might be a
good segue into the Super chats okay
I did not think that was the elephant in
there
wasn't like so continue with more smoke
oh gosh
okay I'm entertained um all right big
boy 702.
kick this man out he's annoying
Joe Pio what a random elephant laughing
emoji um J.E Mitchell I said it before
split no fall and at fault divorce
um impose High limitations on what can
be claimed by the filming party for
no-fault divorce and open it at no fault
but impose a burden of proof for at
fault as well Thoughts by everyone
that's interesting I'm Alistar Horton
um hey Jess what's the situation with
the card
[Music]
I'll email you that's inappropriate to
ask in the show okay
that's life equals credit cards Men's
Life equals debit cards um Harper
Thompson please research what happens to
the Green Ranger jdf he committed
suicide because his wife filed for
divorce and was planning to take
everything from him a um legal money for
tail
is the cure for Queen delusion once smv
has a dollar sign and chicks start
coming up on clearance they'll stop
playing games stop calling each other
queens and be begging for men the UK
Economist please ask your guests if they
think wives would be more loyal if
there's no alimony and no and financial
incentive to divorce
um 90 free tow pie if you want to stay
be happy when they leave um Terrell
Clark she's a walking red flag and
represents Every Man's worst nightmare
she threw a good man away after he moved
her to a better country women are
cold-blooded
um am and women don't think they're
selfish they believe it's selfish
self-love like religion do do you regret
it no I'm nutty of course not my journey
Joe I'm Ohio I've been wondering this
for years not only do they all say they
are tens at and in bed they they think
the same maybe I'm unlucky but for me
it's five percent good twenty percent
okay and 75 I regret thoughts Lawrence
Bullock I would risk half my resources
if I could have Jess and pearl as my
Sister Wives you hear that hello Sister
Wives
um I'm sorry I can't read your name um
Pearl I see you've been taking more
fashion advice showing off those long
legs way to go check am I demanded my
wife um she's still got child support um
the law is crooked am lost 75 to a three
times cheater who hospitalized me she
left me with our kids to go 304 then
ended up living in the basement of her
Guy's new or her guy's mom's house I pay
child support Court ignored my injuries
T Samuels what the hell is an evil what
if a woman's happiness and status is
limited by the potential of her male
partner so once they outperform their
husband they leave an attempt to move up
to avoid fighting in an Ever insecure
man Patrick Ben Bennett
a girl told me I was weird for asking if
I could kiss her after the third day is
it wrong to ask she made a big deal out
of it and totally ghosted me I think if
you if you haven't kissed her about a
third date she's just not into you she's
just taking your money to take to eat
food you just wanted a meal yeah she's
just eating food like yeah I'm sorry if
if I mean look I I wouldn't really
suggest asking but you know I think if
Brad Pitt asked she'd be fine so is is
asking a woman to to kiss her is that
like a turn off though it is to me I've
heard many women say it's it's kind of
cringy but then as a guy you're like
well am I supposed to just jump in but
then that's when you you have to have
that feeling it puts guys in a difficult
situation because if you just go in and
kiss her she's like oh my gosh I can't
believe you just kissed me but if you
ask her she's like oh my gosh I can't
believe you just asked me it's just like
I mean what do you I think if you like
the guy it don't really matter
you know what I mean like if you're
actually in the like into the guy but in
that time it's like we have to have
consent yeah because then you you could
be into the guy and later on down the
road he just kissed me right off the bat
didn't even ask to kiss me and then all
your friends are like oh my gosh I can't
believe he did that to you so
yeah if you're on a date man and
thinking about doing it just kind of do
it but you know and everyone's lucky
you're just a Savage no I'm saying like
don't be scared to not do it to like you
know I mean like that's the inner thing
inside of them bro like make the attempt
go like what they say go eight tenths of
the way and make her come to the two
like the two don't go fully just plant
yourself but go in like you're going for
it
damn you look great thank you okay
okay I went to get her own like
I have to roll my life we gotta get that
let me make sure oh wait there's one or
two more all right good
um Ivan Dimitri got to the guy in the
middle make a video separately if you
have a problem with some dudes we don't
know we are here for Pearl's topic
um Paul zafanzi oh my God what is my man
talking about Alistair Horton you know
the only debate most people can have
effectively is a mass debate okay that's
it
so stupid
ladies and gents we I've got a video for
us to watch and kind of review back to
the divorce topic okay
um yeah I'm gonna play it and then I
want to get you guys's um views on it
blessing when you're ready bro
I'm Fabio Salas and welcome to the
living mad Channel where we talk all
about the American dream so today I want
to talk to you about life after divorce
it's kind of a
it's a pretty big topic nowadays because
as we know lots of marriages are ending
in divorce depending on the statistics
that you read the studies that you read
it's anywhere between 40 as high as 50s
55 percent of marriages ending in
divorce
so why do I want to talk to you about
the horse well
let me tell you I've been divorced
you see that building behind me
19 years ago this November
I was a young 20 year old brand new to
the Marine Corps
and I came right here walked into this
building and got married you see this
building here
this was the last call my son attended
when we were still living together as a
family lastly this building behind me is
the last place where my ex my son and I
all live together as a family
this is actually my first time back here
in six years since we separated
this is Pensacola Florida right now I
live in Illinois and some of you might
know I'm in the military
just so happened that this month in
Pensacola Florida for training
which is just a little bit past a couple
months past of the anniversary of us
splitting up so six years and a couple
months ago
okay this was our last family home
as I walk around and drive around just
all these memories keep coming back to
me
about being married our lives together
and that's what inspired me to make this
video and share with you
you know some of my thoughts on on life
after divorce
so if you've watched enough of my videos
the one thing that I hope you understand
or that you
that you come to get a sense of from my
videos
is first of all I'm talking about the
American dream but the American dream is
not perfect and you need to understand
that
we we a lot of times we have this
picture that the American dream is you
know we grow up we get the perfect job
that makes us happy pays a six-figure
salary we get married we stay married
until we're old and
basically till death do us part we have
the kids the kids are good in school
they go to Great Schools grow up go to
college you get the picture we have this
idea of what the American dream is
but real life's not like that real life
is messy and it will kick you hard when
you least expect it and it will knock
you down when you least expect it
but part of living the American dream is
being able to get back up
to Rise Up From the Ashes when
everything's trying to hold you down
that's part of the American dream it's
not always going to be easy and divorce
is one of those things that none of us
ever aspired for none of us ever think
when I grow up I want to get married and
get divorced five times that's I
seriously doubt that's anybody's goal I
know it certainly wasn't my goal so
please do understand that when I talk
about the American dream
I'm not saying if you're a divorcee
you're not living the American dream if
your kids aren't with you and not living
the American dream if you're not making
60 Grand a year or more you're not
living the American dream because that's
not what it's about the American dream
is very different for every single
person out there it's different for me
because I'm sure it's going to be
different for
all of you watching
so that said how do we live the American
dream after the voice
uh there's a million things that I wish
I could tell you but I want to try to
keep this video short so I'm gonna share
with you just four things
that I've taken away from my experiences
after my own divorce
that I hope can help you not just for
your own divorce but
maybe you know a friend who's divorced
or a family member who's divorced or
going through the voice so I think this
is something that's beneficial for
everybody out there so the first thing
is when you're going through a divorce
you should seek help
I will tell you when when I first
separated with my ex and I first
separated I got moved to Japan she
stayed here in the states with our son
and I got moved to Japan I'm in the
military they said boom go
that was very hard having my son away
away from me my ex it was basically like
my whole life changed the blink of an
eye
and there were times where things just
felt so overwhelming
just so hard I felt so alone so
desperate
but I would sit in my room sit on my
couch and just cry
and that's not something I generally
share with people but I tell you because
I want you to understand
that that's that's how real things get
that's how hard things get and I'm not
somebody who generally cries I'm not
it's not it's not part of my culture
being a marine it's definitely not you
know something Marines do so it's
it felt unnatural but it was necessary
and I had to go through that and it
helped me process those emotions but I
knew that I needed to seek help
so another thing that I did is I spoke
to a counselor we had a counselor on
base
who helped people dealing with family
issues and I will go talk to her once a
week I did that for I think about six
months or so
and and she would give me advice and
tips on on things and I would just vent
to her about called my son yesterday and
he wouldn't answer you know whatever the
case may be
I also made a couple friends that I'm
still friends with today that were a
huge help to me at that time that I was
able to confide in
and the great thing about having good
friends is that they're not going to
judge you they're going to listen and
they're going to give you advice when
you need it and just basically help you
through those tough times
so for me that was huge the friends that
I had
um and the counselor and just basically
basically get into a point where I
understood I can't do this alone
I'm not somebody who generally seeks
help I like to think I can do things on
my own
but I had to accept this is not one of
those times I need help I need somebody
to help me get through this tough time
so that's the first thing I want you to
remember is sometimes you got to seek
help
the second thing that I'll tell you that
helped me get through the tough times is
fine find something that makes you happy
so for me while I was in Japan
I got into scuba diving had never done
scuba diving before I got into
woodworking I had done woodworking
before but never as much
I rode my motorcycle a lot I've always
been into riding motorcycles but I was
doing it a lot there
exercising was a very regular part of my
routine riding bicycles and running all
over the island
so there was a lot of things that I got
into that I used to try to fill up my
free time so I would have less time
sitting at home feeling alone feeling
depressed
now I don't want you to think that I'm
telling you you should try to escape
your problems or try to escape your
negative emotions because that's not
going to be healthy in the long run
you've got to deal with the pain you've
got to confront the pain as hard as that
may be you've got to confront the pain
so if you if you need to cry cry if you
need to go talk to a counselor a
chaplain
a friend a family member whoever go talk
to them you've got to deal with those
emotions
what I don't want you to do or what I
suggest you don't do
is dwell in those negative emotions all
the time so I don't want you to get off
work go to your house and cry every
single day for three years four years
five years on end you've got to make
time for yourself to make yourself happy
again whether that's Hobbies hanging out
with friends vacations maybe you're at
the painting whatever you like doing
do that do that do it for you very
explicit
um
I guess you kind of get the gist there
um the guy went for a divorce I want to
ask a question after hearing that
um to the guys have you guys ever gone
through a breakup and it's made you feel
like that guy Phil
uh I'd be capping if I say I didn't
because yeah yeah no I'd be camping if I
say I didn't that that feeling that it's
almost because you know you can't get it
back and it's the frustration of not
being able to to to hold things down
you're not getting overwhelmed when you
feel like you're gonna explode and
there's no other way to explode so the
waterfalls might end up running but yeah
I've definitely felt very similar
obviously not the same level because
this is a deeper situation but
basically I skim some of that
Mr aberrant preach
Mr elephant in the room that's what I'm
saying like anyway no go and have you
Abby Abby Boom for a breakup like that
and made you feel like that yeah of
course that's how I know what what to do
like I'm telling you a lot what to do
when you get a breakup I said that time
ago listen go in a room cry in front of
like Cry by yourself don't do it in
front of someone like get out like in
terms of just like emotionally get it
out that's why that's what for me
because the like if I got all the crying
out there was no more crime do you know
what I mean there's a certain time when
you look at and look at yourself in the
mirror when you're crying as well
you get over it quicker
I remember I was um I got I had a mad
break up and I was singing nanko lucky
you lucky you you got some woman to go
home to I gotta find me myself a woman
well yeah I was crying crying balling
balling all like dribble coming down in
that and I looked at myself in the
mirror
but I've got a girl's like what we can
do that bro [ __ ] is that yeah what are
you doing bro like what I'm saying
that's not you bro you know what I'm
saying you get girl so let me start
talking to yourself no but she's the one
nah she's not the one bro we talking
about like you could you'd have that
conversation with yourself
an advisement to you know if you've got
guys around you as well they'll help you
get through it you know what I'm saying
especially P guys you know they might
not be like yo can we go out and you
know forget about her right now
no but I want to call it now forget
about it don't call her like that you
know something like that some real guys
ladies have you ever had a man
cry to you
like Peggy like oh that cry should make
you like yeah yeah how did that make you
feel
guys like cry in front of me but not beg
me to stay not cry me like
baby please no go on pal tell your story
go ahead
oh no I just
yeah that's that's happened to me
um did it make you look at him any
differently
oh this is gonna make me look bad no no
um
it's not really attractive to have a guy
like like crying and begging for you to
come back you know what I mean like
women don't want a man that needs you as
you know this you know that probably
doesn't make me look the best yeah but
I'm just being honest like we don't want
a guy that falls apart if we're not in
the their life like the only guy that's
fine without us and we know we can like
depend on so if you're like crying and
begging for us back it's like
it's not attractive to us typically told
that to the guy that's boiling in it but
you know that you feel like your whole
life is gone like hang on I want to hear
from the ladies that have happened to
you
um yeah I actually kind of liked it I
don't know I I thought it was
um
I thought is shared like strength that
you know he could share emotion to me
and obviously not like becking me but
like crying and being like you know I
actually love you like you know I want
to make this work like and he got tears
in his eyes and I kind of liked it yeah
did you get back with him
um no
yeah
that's a great show that was a fantastic
show
um
but like I'm a empath so I feel the
people's emotions so you know if the guy
cries I cry you know so it's like come
and cry all together because you know we
you know
you know I like all the people and
that's the thing it doesn't matter break
up or not they are awesome people and
all the guys the awesome people and
everybody cry everybody has the same
emotions as women you know and we all
share the same things and so many
different things and you know
everybody's inspiring and everybody's
like
unique guys have the same emotions as
women
uh
in the long run deep down
yeah we all have the same emotions it
just like depends like some emotions
it's like
hidden some of motion small active so
emotions like we can show usually we
keep our Poker Face you know when we
don't want to show any emotions you
don't think women are more emotional
than men by and large I do I do I do I
do I do visibly emotional I think I
think we get deep we don't you know we
don't express it enough do you know I
think guys cry like that or it affects
guys so much because I think guys love
idealistically
and I think women love opportunistically
collaborate on that I think women love
you based on the opportunity to love you
and
they're always looking for a better
opportunity to love somebody else hence
the monkey branching hence the reason
why when when the divorce has happened
you know she's got someone just there
whereas guys love idealistically when
they fall in love they're like this is
it done this is me for the rest of my
life I'm gonna live all my years out and
this is gonna be me and I think it
affects guys psychologically more so
than it does women well that's what they
say about women that they wait at the
finish line and [ __ ] the winners yeah
yeah and and it's unfortunate but it's
it's true I mean if the number one
reason
um for divorce or one of the number one
reasons is financial because you can't
act like that's not true yeah and like
like just being honest how long are you
gonna if a dude loses his job how long
are you staying how long is he not
working but a girl could lose her job
and he's gonna support her 100 where
it's like I mean you know you could and
even mental they'll stay with a fat
chick too I have a question for the men
if you're in a situation where you
um like both of you all working your
wife or girlfriend whatever the
situation is and you end up losing your
job would you feel
demasculated or will you feel weird
having a woman provide for you until you
were able to yeah it's definitely like
one that's a pride thing but two has
also been instilled my mom always made
it be known like yo don't don't let no
one do for you that way they can't say
nothing in the front in your face when
they do get emotional feel some type of
way so in that sense like yeah
but you know I actually learned the hard
way with that
um so interesting a few years back when
I was you know in a relationship
um
I was a
Sole Provider for the relationship and
the and the family and um I got laid off
of my job and I was
um I was actually yeah I didn't have a
job for like three months and I remember
I specifically remember always being the
breadwinner of any relationship that
I've been in
and I'd been like with this one for like
six years and it had been three months
and the switch in her attitude within
that three months really surprised me
I was just like I've been provided
[ __ ] six years like just chill the
[ __ ] out do you know what I mean it's
like like you're acting like I'm some
[ __ ] bum or some [ __ ] don't worry
I'll get another job but it's like oh
but we need this and this and you're
supposed to be doing this and I was like
why it's only been [ __ ] three
and that's what I realized you know what
yeah women are very interesting
creatures do you know do you know I
think some it kind of plays into I think
when girls are like um in a relationship
I think they watch other girls in
relationships
and compared their relationship to that
other relationship you've not seen the
bads in that relationship of course not
because that that girl's not going to
show you that you know what I mean so
that image what like I'll say like you
know girls are like oh Sierra Russell
Wilson they're like they wouldn't they
all want that what they never show you
what's what's their bad issues until
they break up and then they'll be like
oh what did he do to her what did she do
you know I mean but all the time now is
I want to be like that relationship I
want to have that relationship probably
you've got that relationship but you
left it well I hear what you're saying
women look at all of these you know
Beyonce and Jay-Z's and Rihanna's and
whoever's they're they're with and do
relationship goals yeah and all that
kind of stuff so it's it's a women like
idolizing relationships and it's like
one of the reasons why relationships
break down is because women are looking
at other people's relationships
expecting it to be like that then when
they get there it's like well Brianna
did this with ASAP Rocky you know what I
mean he's not taking me
he didn't buy me one thousand roses
how dare he
no I think I think most is more simpier
than that go on do you know what I mean
like you know how certain times like you
know say treat them mean keep them Keen
we'll be like some people's Mantra like
how they do their things and then some
that girl she wants to be with the guy
that she thinks is going to be like
Russell Wilson so he's supposed to be
nice tall attractive
but still be like Prince Charming don't
step out wrong don't say anything wrong
Russell Wilson is a Sim though
to be honest no but even if he was a Sim
like I can't really say he's a sympathy
if he's got bare money no of course you
can he's simping for Sierra
Sierra is currently twerking on the top
of cars bro that's a lot that's a lack
of respect that she has for him
and so he's simping because he's
accepting that right wait what what's
the definition of you look for sin pin
then all right all right first of all
look Sierra was a single mother when he
got with her right features baby she's
got she's got one of the most notorious
like like
the modern day like pimps babies right
and she's gone from him to Russell
Wilson some nice clean-cut dude like and
you're taking care of The Pimps baby
the reason why I'm saying that because
I've been there did you get what I'm
saying like I've I've taken care of
another man's challenge you know what
I'm saying so I know what it's like to
be like you know what like there's no
benefit here were you simping yeah of
course okay the thing is
this is a thing like you I I believe
like you've got to learn from your your
life your the things that you experience
in life and it's like yeah of course
I've been I think every man's been a
symptom for a woman at some point do you
think Russell will and Wilson could
afford to pay for Sierra's child of
course he can and not even think about
it yeah but that's what I mean when I
say the difference between sympathy but
the problem is it's time his time is
Super valuable and he has to spend time
emotionally investing in the kid right
like that's if anything you could argue
he spends more because his time is worth
so much
we're talking about Sierra who's a
musician she's also got her own money
she's also out there so we're not saying
we're not I'm not talking I'm not
comparing it as to that's my whole point
where where girls are comparing
themselves to Sierra and Russell Wilson
like they got their type of money they
could afford to live nice and cushy but
whatever you know what I'm trying to say
it's not the same when you and your
little nine-to-five job working for
Tesco and I'm like no I want that kind
of relationship it doesn't it doesn't
matter in some of these women's eyes
whether they're working at the corner
shop or they're working at Tesla
dealership making like great money
doesn't matter they see they see these
celebrities they see these famous people
doing XYZ and they're like if my man's
not doing that for me I don't want it
and that's just how it's how it's like
came about nowadays and it's just in
society if he's not paying in for this
pain for that I saw a video and it was
like if a man's not paying for my hair
which is like a thousand dollars a month
my nails 500 plus this that and third is
like no he can't he can't be with me and
it's like well what are you doing do you
can you afford all that right now I am
the table I have a question for the
ladies
um how much would you say your
submission costs
what do you mean submission
um actually my first question so would
you submit to a man meaning that you
trust his authority and his judgment so
if there's big decisions you you trust
him to make decisions
and my second question is if so how much
would that cost so let's say he said
quit your job I want you to be home with
the kids how much would you have to make
for you to trust his judgment
it's a good question I mean there's not
really the price to it you know you kind
of trust the human being congenital or
trust the person or you not so fifteen
thousand pounds a year you trust him
there's no money involved at all in my
kind of relationship in general okay
whatever like money comes along it's
like I do share I don't care because the
money comes and money goes so there's
always investment so and then I think so
15 he makes 15 000 pounds a year
okay he's a Brokey and but that's the
thing I don't really care how much man
makes like once I can make the money
with that man together that's like where
there is the partnership no but I'm
saying like he's not changing his income
so a lot of girls will try to answer the
question because they'll say oh he can
make more in the future no no no no no
this isn't build a bomb
he's a bum he's gonna be a bum so he
makes 15 000 pounds a year
um you think he's cute whatever
um you're dating him
do you trust him to make decisions
you mean our decision is a personal so
so I'll give you an example I don't give
anybody permission to make decisions for
me okay so you would never trust a man
to make decisions
until some certain point I don't know
what kind of decisions have to be made
I'm talking about life decisions so
let's say do we live in the city or the
country
um how much do you budget each month how
many kids are we gonna have okay but
everybody think it's like it's mutual
agreement but the whole point is at some
point you guys are going to disagree at
some point right like it might not you
guys might agree on 90 of things but
that 10 when you guys disagree it's
saying you know what I'm I'm gonna trust
him to make decisions would you do that
or no
well if the man's not stable dead end so
we're like no you know I I don't know I
agree no I agree I don't think you
should at 15 000 pounds he like I think
that's mad but I'm sorry about the money
again like he can make 15 000 he can
make a hundred [ __ ] thousand but at
the same time it depends what he's gonna
do with that money even with 15 where
he's spending what he's doing like with
his lifestyle like what what he knows
like and is he progressing is he growing
poets if the man stays at least
so there's like there's like I wouldn't
be with that man okay
I agree with you you shouldn't okay
that's that's not a lot of money so I'm
saying how much does he have to make for
you to be with him
what's the minute like we all know
there's a minimum but it's not about the
money I I understand it's not only money
but there has to be a money component
so you're just asking how much yeah like
Infinity how much yeah how much for you
to trust his judgment
the Judgment based on the money it's
like no the Judgment should be based on
the values on the truth
that doesn't pay bills man I can
understand based off your your original
question how much does your submission
cost you when it comes to
um when it comes to a man and him being
in his masculinity you should want to be
able to submit regardless so I can
understand where she's coming from
um
to answer your question Pearl
um uh it would be more than 15. but
I don't know
what's the what's the average in the UK
I think it's like 38 38 000 I think okay
so what I had in my head I would say 50
minimum 50 okay 50. yeah okay is this
like a year or a month yeah
a year who do you know making 50k a week
I mean if that's it
the average salary is 38 000 pounds when
you say 50 do you mean dollars or pounds
just pounds okay which would be what
like 40
[Music]
we got one person who hasn't answered
the question yet okay
um it's quite a hard question it's like
do I wanna like let him
do all of or take all the decisions and
self because for me I'm quite like a
person
um I like to do all of that stuff myself
you know and I'm I want a future for
myself like I'm trying to
create a future for myself
um so I don't know if I it's it's a
really hard question exactly do you are
you do you hold on to your Independence
is that what you're saying like it's not
that I'm like oh I don't want anyone in
my life or I don't you know if it
happens it happens you know but right
now in my life that that I wouldn't have
any like specific time for like a
relationship that would work properly
you know like but um
I don't know it's hard I would I would
kind of want to find a balance between
both of us um but to answer your
question it would
obviously be like around the same amount
the money yeah about 50. yeah but but
that is so hard like I personally I
probably wouldn't do it if you're if
your man became if you were with your
man and he was you know making good
money and you're married to him you too
had like a good great laugh together and
he
fell on hard times and then became quite
broke for a while would you do you think
you'd end up leaving him no no I would I
would either be the one taking your job
maybe trying to support us you know in
the end is is not about like
um leaving based on money you know is it
can be for some people but for me no I
would I wouldn't do that I said I said
because you know like when it comes to
divorce one of the major reasons is
because of finances
I grew I grew up sort of like with both
of my parents and also
mom kind of being divorced and and then
her like taking care of two children and
I saw her working hard for us so for me
it's like no I would I would take over
or find trying to help or you know what
I mean
it's stupid to well I won't say that I
think it's
insensitive and ignorant to leave
somebody from a woman's perspective if a
man is taking care of you providing for
you and then he falls on a hard time and
all of a sudden you're just like you
know what
you can't you're not making any money
you're a bum blah blah I'm Gonna Leave
You it's just like whoa he had every
chance in the world to leave you because
he's provided for you essentially you're
the bum so I feel like there's some
women that don't think of it from that
perspective like
your your man has followed on Hard Times
whatever the situation is you should
want to be like okay now I can't I can
help him out in every way possible
because typically men are like no I want
to support you now it's like okay oh I
get the chance to support my man however
long it may be do you guys think
relationships can work where the woman
makes more than the man for an extended
period of time no
no
yeah I think so if the woman doesn't
come at it at a conniving and like uh
very like oh I'm I'm making the money
now you see but that's exactly how it's
going to be whether it's in your face or
Soul no matter what it's always going to
be there it took too long to come down
to the night out you used to do the last
toilet but it's just gonna be the same
thing over I have a question for you
Jess yeah so all right let's say let's
say your YouTube channel just goes crazy
subscribe subscribe to her Channel
subscribe now you're bringing home 100K
a year now so you you marry a guy that
makes 50k um or 60 in the U.S
my question is
he wants to buy you want you have a
certain house that you want he has a
certain house that he wants are you
willing even though you bringing in more
money for the house to let him pick
am I willing to give up that house yeah
so you want let's say you want a four
bedroom house he wants a two-bedroom
house are you willing to give up your
dream house and let him pick even though
you're bringing in more money what I
would do is I would see how we can meet
in the middle no that's not that's not
submission
that's not submission it's not meat in
the middle it's like his way okay
even though you're bringing in more
money
I think we we already know no
no it's uh because I it may not be like
oh yes automatically but it'd be like
okay is this beneficial like if if he
thinks it's beneficial like that house
is beneficial for us in the future we
wouldn't have to up and move tell them
okay yeah sure but I would want to
understand like where he was coming from
and why he would want that house instead
of the other one I have to say like oh
mine's the best we should get it but if
he says like financially right now we
should down to grade or go this way I'd
be like okay I see it I see where you're
coming so who's this final decision it
would be
it would be his final decision I because
I I'm the type of person I want to
understand where the person's coming
from and just saying like do you think
that's common no yeah yeah no it's not
common anyone has been in the long-term
relationship as a man knows that your
money as a man is
everyone's money and the woman's money
is her money um
have you experienced it yeah yeah
just general stuff when you go out even
even if you're taking out my siblings or
their siblings it makes no difference my
money is everyone's money but their
money just goes on themselves I have a
question for the guy go ahead bro I was
just gonna say I like spoilers guys
oh yeah I like to buy like good presents
yeah I've gone broke
spoiling guys yeah yeah unfortunately a
lot of guys would say they like that but
when we get down into it it's kind of
awkward to kind of accept it really yeah
oh yeah I feel like it like because I
feel like I'd want to do something we
could do together like tickets to
something
yeah like a sports game like a football
game because then when we're there I'll
buy the drinks and the food because
you've already covered the tick fast
being there like that's mine yeah as a
guys have you ever been on a date where
a woman's offered to pay
because I actually had this conversation
with my version about the whole painting
and I had to let it know like you're my
bridging you know like you can go harder
you can pay for yours you know she was a
girlfriend no she was a girl who was a
friend yeah yeah right okay so I was
having to talk about nah yeah um unless
we're in a relationship like yeah no
females actually paid or even offered to
come and pay is it weird I feel like
when I say I I feel like
um I've had a I've had a I've had an
incident
um with a woman who made a lot I would
date a woman who made a lot of money
like she was like a like a hedge fund
individual she was only like 200k right
like a month like 200k a year like oh
she was making good money more money
than I was making you know what I'm
saying and I and I specifically remember
it's a great day you know great girl and
you know the bill came at the end of the
night right and I kind of had my jacket
on the chair and my wallet and my jacket
right and I just went okay cool and I
kind of bent down to kind of get my
wallet out and she just took her phone
and went
and paid like the guy and I was like the
[ __ ] are you doing and she was like oh
well I'm just paying and I was like are
you trying to [ __ ] emasculate me or
some [ __ ] like on the day and she and
the thing is in her head she was like no
like I'm just used to kind of like
paying because I make money and then the
thing is
listen I had no problem with the girl
but I just said that the mindset
I was just like um that's gonna be a
problem now but that's going to be a
problem that's lit because think about
when she's with our virgins they do the
same thing so the fact that she's gonna
on a date it's the same type of vibe
like that's that's pretty that's
beautiful now for me it would be a
problem because then it's like I don't
want anybody having like something over
me like that I don't want a woman having
that over me then you've got the next
one what if she doesn't make more money
but she just wanted to treat you it'd
probably be different
because
she's doing it for a treat not just
because her Persona is I pay was it was
it was it more hurt no I mean was it
more her attitude about it no her
attitude was I'm telling you her
attitude was fine she she was just in a
mindset that she just used to paying for
everything and so for me if you're in
that mindset if you're just used to
paying for everything it's going to be a
problem me and you were going to battle
in this relationship if if it goes
further down the line because I'm just
gonna be like okay cool and I don't want
to be battling with you with you know
who pays for stuff like I just don't I
don't want that right now
say sorry say again rate her out of 10.
no no don't do that
I have a question no I'm not saying that
she's not a cool girl but I'm saying
that hey if she was like super model you
wouldn't leave because she paid for a
and b if she if she was if she was a
supermodel would she offer to pay no um
the way my mind works is I try to look
further down the road at things and my
whole thing is you could be a 10 out of
10 in looks yeah but if I'm looking to
get into a relationship with you I'm
trying to see the things within the
relationship that are going to school
Court calls like a Schism within a
relationship and I know that would have
caused a Schism that would have pissed
me off so I'm just like it's not even
really worth it but what's your attend
though
she was a she was a nice looking girl
see let's just say that she was a nice
looking girl I don't go on dates with
whales
just saying for the guys now if you say
you
um you're dating somebody and they got
to the club for their birthday and they
bring all their girls and everything do
you think
because this is I've seen this in a
video where she brought her girl to the
date no no it's not a date Club
celebrate you and her and then her girls
are out of the club do you think you are
obligated to pay for her stuff and her
friends stuff like drinks and stuff at
the club well for her birthday for her
birthday what I'm obligated to do is pay
for you so I if seriously over the club
then I'll put money for the bucket your
bridges are out for you for your
birthday so as your virgins when you
don't know me go out and I'm not there
y'all be paying for your [ __ ] right so
then the rest of them put in I'll put
inside the percentage because you're my
girl I'm out here with you but they have
to be put in I'm gonna cover it for them
as well they can go home otherwise we
can go out with my guys and oh my guys
they'll all cover the whole set for you
we will have a late night depends how
expensive it is irrelevant it's not
their birthdays no but it's like a
birthday party you're setting up in it
it's like you know what I mean
anything expensive if you've got enough
money how do you guys feel about paying
ladies
like would you go 50 50 with a guy are
you okay with that I usually pay for the
guys too like oh you'll pay for things
like I always get something to somebody
you know coffee or whatever snack there
you go take it
yeah it's like a thing you know when
you're together in a group or whatever
or with your
boyfriend or something I don't mind
paying like but I've had the same
similar
um
thing where I went up and paid and he
was like
you know he got he kind of had to tell
me like that he stopped kind of going
out with me because he didn't like me
paying and when he didn't have enough
money and I was earning money he would
still not go out with me because he
really he just like yeah
anyway in my thing in my instance when
that happened it wasn't a pride thing
because like I said when she done that I
said listen please just don't do that
again because it was an emasculating
experience and it seemed like I know
it's a pride thing no but I said it I
don't think it came from a malicious
place when she'd done it you know what I
mean it was just for me I just thought
you didn't even say anything you just
thought yeah there you go it's done and
I'm just like I don't like I didn't like
it oh maybe she does it because she
doesn't want the awkward moment of you
saying should we go horse that because
she's got she's got enough money so she
could just ended the whole this is what
I'm saying she could just end the whole
issue of that just by paying for it
but you took the wrong react like not
wrong reaction but you had the no she
liked it afterwards
laughs I'm not saying anything
that was paid
all right well yeah me I mean that I
don't really go dating because of these
kind of situations because I feel like
it's forcedent how are you gonna get
your wives if you don't go there
anyways well personally as well for me I
feel like
I don't know if it's just me but
sometimes just paying and sharing the
guy that you're not like there for the
money or you're like oh you can pay for
yourself I don't know for me personally
I just felt that guys might like that
but I don't know no I'm saying if you
can't if you can't if you or listen if
you can't pay for a date why are you
going on a date
yeah as a man
it's true but then but then where does
the equality kick in though that's
that's what I'm wondering for like women
like women say they want equality and
you know they want you know to be equal
with men like where does that kick in on
a date I'm just kind of laid back like I
don't know like if he wants to split it
we can I don't know like if he doesn't
okay like I'm just you won't see him any
differently if he wants to split the
split the day
um
don't cap no I mean okay okay I think
it's appreciated but I still I
understand the fact that like you know
traditional women like get courted
traditionally and I think if you're not
like 22 and a virgin you're not
traditional so it's kind of like we're
asking to be courted like traditional
women but we're not anymore so I kind of
understand where the guys are coming
from but I'm just I don't know I'm laid
back I think if I like the guy he can
probably get away with it so do you
think it's worse do you think it's worse
yeah check this out do you think it's
worse if he can't afford it and you pay
for him or he can't afford it and you
pay for him
I said splints that pay for him but
um if he can't it's worse if he can't
afford it I can't if you can't afford it
yeah yeah of course uh yeah what do you
mean so if he could afford it I'm just
being honest all things equal if one guy
has money and one guy doesn't have money
like women are more attracted to the guy
with money yeah yeah like all things
being equal yes
that's the way it goes it's a poor World
for for broke guys bro but as for the
first date I do believe that the man not
supposed to but it would be actually
supposed to pay for the woman's meal for
the first time
to me I would just think he's not into
me you know what I mean like he doesn't
want to pay for you yeah because to me
if a guy really likes a girl he's not
gonna let her pay how about I'm testing
you yeah I'm gonna say the same thing
to get this appointment over and over
again where Gala just using them for the
for the first date yeah yeah it's like
no on the on the fifth date now we can
start talking about spending a little
money not about on Thursday I just met
you know that's what I'm saying I get it
so that's why I said I'm pretty laid
back I don't think I'd really hold it
over his head if you like the guy I'm
sorry he doesn't have to spend money on
you and I stand by this I've seen I've
seen like guys say that to test a woman
right you go out on a date and you you
know you you get the meal and then you
say oh damn I forgot my wallet and then
see if she says oh that's okay I can pay
for it and then if she says that he's
like okay don't worry I'll just yeah
I'll pay for it is that not the correct
answer no because some women are like
well I ain't man you better go wash some
dishes or some [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying that just let you know
I just don't think it's that big of a
deal like early on let's just see how
where it goes I don't know on the first
on the first date I'll ask like oh like
do you want to split it because I don't
want the man to assume like oh you're
supposed to be paying for it did he ask
you out though if he asked you out on a
date shouldn't he be paying nah nah
because then it's like they have to
assume that they're gonna pay for
everything it's just like I don't want
that to be something that you
automatically assume whenever you take a
female out like you're you have to pay
so that's why I asked like do you want
to split it I mean I'm fool you want in
it I'm just like
different gen I'm just like if I ask a
woman out on a date I'm gonna pay but
it's a funny thing with the testing
people you know like if the men testing
women so it's like exactly the same with
the women as well it's like if he's
gonna appear or no if like he's gonna
appear on the first date it's like you
know what actually that's like the guy
like in general there's like it's a plus
in a way because he asks you out it's
the first time
and come approach you and be like hey
let's go out so naturally because you
have to be the guy and go forward and do
what the man's supposed to do you have
to ask them out
the bit no you don't think I don't I
don't get so after the after the first
day if you say hey like would you like
to like go what was the first day the
first day was the park right
whatever you guys
this is a Vibe especially in the
summertime yeah
what if she asked you out to dinner like
hey like if you're not doing anything
this weekend let's go out to dinner
which is she obligated to pay then or is
it you still have to pay since you're no
you asked me to come up but listen y'all
befriend that day I got my money all
right cool but me I'm coming out yeah
for the minimum you're paying for
yourself yeah because I'm thinking about
me making sure that I got for me because
you asked me so now I definitely have to
make sure that I got jealous that I'm
like I don't know okay do you guys feel
like you go up more above and beyond if
you like a girl more
yeah of course
yeah a girl a girl a captain so okay
okay a girl that you're really okay okay
a girl that you're really into that you
feel like maybe is punching a little bit
for you I feel bad when you do it okay
would you ask her to split it
I keep saying it depends because it's
like this yeah if she's got pee and like
you see it you say how you say you
forgot your wallet and she she said no
don't worry I got it so it's like so why
wasn't you able to go horse with it
anyway
it kind of sense like why why did you
have to wait for me to do it before we
the discussion is that we're going horse
on this like why do we have to have this
discussion whether or not we go halves
or IP or whatever that's why I don't go
dating because it's like too much
pressure on that sense do you remember
that thing I told you about from um
yeah it's pretty gorgeous gorgeous dude
we had that top beforehand that yo like
listen we're going out to eat where do
you want to go she suggested wrong
because I said oh I like that I've been
there a couple times it's a bit more
Japanese space
though what's the name of it
r-o-k-a anyway we shouldn't be proponent
yeah we ain't got no money from them so
this is something that she suggested so
I'm like cool but you know it's a bit
pricey she's like oh I didn't know so I
just sent her the many prices that I've
took him on my phone like you know like
this what's on the menu these are the
prices for the for the stuff you
understand at cobot watch this so we've
understood what it is from the beginning
so if you still want to go there know
that this is how much it costs I'm also
going to let you know cap but I'm going
to let you know that my financial
situation is a bit Ticky this week
Netflix bills a car I don't know so on
and so forth is coming out just to see
what then what you're actually going to
be do you understand the I feel like
that talk has to happen beforehand
otherwise you're gonna get there and I'm
not a fool I will look you dead in your
eye and slap my PM card and be like the
food was nice I enjoy here so you tried
to go for dates you
would just put half your money down and
then go
because I can't just expect so you can't
just expect and if you do that's an
insult to me I'm my idiot I might assim
it's not gonna happen so yeah slap down
my heart and go back I just feel like
wow I kind of I'm gonna stand on this I
feel like if you had a girl that you
were really into you would not ask you
would do that I feel like these are kind
of girls that you're like ah maybe and
if a girl is kind of uh you're not
taking her to Rocco bro yeah but you're
testing us you're not taking it to
hakkasan you ain't taking that to no no
I mean you gotta tester McDonald's
you're testing it even more now because
because now you're you're you're having
a battle of yourself I agree if she
suggested the restaurant I could see
where you're coming from but like I feel
like if you really like a girl you're
trying to impress her I didn't say other
ways yeah food is like paying for food
or paying for stuff in general is not
one of them you know like we there's so
much things that we can do for free
around London that I'll pay for the Uber
if that's the case I'll pay for you but
we can do other bits and pieces we can
spend time going look at tandem bikes
and whatnot there's things you can do
that don't cause peas like that no I I
agree with you but I'm like why would
you invite her somewhere and then ask
her to split it no no I didn't buy I
didn't buy it that's what I'm saying I
feel like on a first date if you liked a
girl you would try to impress her so if
you didn't want to do the dinner you
could do something free that's still fun
like you'd still want to impress her
right or you just don't want to impress
women you like but then who who really
what's the point goes on a first date
who really goes all out on a first date
though because I know I don't like the
bottom line is you know I was in the
10-year relationship I've always said I
know what grand gestures are yeah I know
if I'm gonna go hakkasan or another
cough or even Roka or something spent
money that's gonna be my woman I'm doing
that for my my woman I'm not doing that
for any random girl I don't might not
even see you in a week's time I don't
know who the hell you are why would I be
spending a couple hundred pounds on you
and I'm not probably not even gonna see
you next week because she's not weird
because she's taught no it's not
happening I would arrange a different
type of date no no I'm saying no no no
no oh he's talking about for not for you
personally but I'm talking about for
other people why certain men would go do
these grand gestures is because they're
kind of punching above their league in a
sense so you know I mean I need to
impress her because bro I know boring on
me ain't gonna do nothing you know I
mean so instead of them going to the gym
or you know they got some something
special about them they'll spend money
some so some guys their game is money so
when I'm true so when I'm looking out
for certain girls I'm looking out for is
you are you fallible for the game of
money
do you get what I'm trying to say
I need to test you straight away because
if I really like you that means now the
test is even more on because now I know
the consequences if you leave me I'm
gonna work situation because I'm the one
that fell in I'm yeah I'm gonna be
heartbroken like the same crying in the
bathroom looking at yourself in the
mirror yeah adorable yeah you don't want
to go through that so you start putting
up walls and stop like you know like
you've got all right she broke down that
one she's got like 10 more like this is
getting kind of scary now like you know
I mean like like she's doing the right
things she's saying the right thing
she's doing the right things and dating
is amazing
Dayton is a major thing when it comes to
that like dating etiquette so I choose
not to get him if she calls me and be
like yo come on a date I'll be like okay
she's talking something different you
know but she if she's expecting me to
call like which is what eight nines and
tens do anyway you know like I don't see
no eight nines and tens running down
that one guy unless that one guy is
actually like um
a top 10 man anyway
tune indeed you know so if I'm just a no
nine to five guy working doing whatever
I know I have to go after that buddy if
I'm trying to take her seriously which I
don't do I don't subscribe to that
anyway because
yo I'm the law of 100 in it like I told
you hell um we got super chats before we
round up yeah let me refresh it
um guys like the video um on your way in
there's over 2 000 people watching I I
like is free there should be 2 000 likes
on here
um okay King P beats I see what Jess is
like as a potential mate oh yeah that's
good yeah the chat is loving you today I
I'm 22 and I make 60k in the U in US
Dollars still seen as a Brokey in my
opinion I'm 90 free-toe pie
um R2 are women are too dumb for
hypotheticals
um Lawrence Bullock Russell Wilson's
first wife cheated on him with one of
his teammates and then there's Sierra
he's 100 assemb Alistair Horton question
what's the difference for a mat for men
between a modern relationship I'm not
per personal long-term
um prostitute
oh gosh um 93 to apply um Suka the lady
um closest close to Pearl um whoa if you
want marriage without divorce I
recommend Eastern Europe hot chicks
traditional and divorce rates are two
times smaller than the US and the UK
Vikings what she's Europeans
um Viking and saying there's no honesty
there's no future matter many modern
marriages are composed of one or both
Partners attempting to deceive the other
for personal gain what up Pearl and crew
I enjoy the content I'm divorced and it
sucks she cheated says I was too much of
a father figure what the f twins are
nine years old
um night Commander Pro I watch you grow
from your time on Fresh infant you have
done awesome job and much love and
respect by the way I look in smoking
um Deo to the Red Queen Pearl and her
men and women may you continue to bring
us quality content congrats on over 700k
let's get it t Samuels gotta go glad to
finally hear you were all alive keep up
the strong work red pill
am5 nah buddy five divorces you good
nobody's judging you crying every day
five you set up franchises my guy at
each Soldier Gus can you talk about
women celebrating divorce
um Ivan um to the guy in the middle oh
wait I read this one okay that's it
all right uh folks before we leave we're
gonna get some final thoughts on um
divorce before we go
um let's start over there with the
actual divorcee
[Music]
final thoughts well in life you you know
when you're getting married you never
thought you're gonna get divorced too
you know so life happens it's ups and
downs and that's how we're growing
through the hard times
we're growing we're getting better
we're learning something if we're not
we're going to repeat the same cycle
just with another person if we do we're
gonna pass on and we're just gonna move
on somewhere else and we all continue
passing our own path following our own
part and that's it everybody has a
personal Journey you know to follow so
it's everything is personal whatever we
are going through it is quite common
because everybody got to believe that we
all supposed to act the same we're
supposed to watch the same things and be
influenced by the same things and that's
how we get them up and away because like
we don't know what is true which is now
anymore
you know
okay
Yeah
final thoughts I love just pearly things
I love the channel man I love it when
you're talking about Pearl in general or
just Channel I'm too
no that's that's the problem I love just
pearly things Channel because Pearl is a
host on just pearly things Channel Pearl
gives you time to talk and say what you
your views to come across which I
appreciate you don't get that on a lot
of other platforms
so if you have your views that you want
to put on come to just barely things
you know nice next
final thoughts
final forts in the forest
[Music]
um make sure that you're making the
right choice
[Music]
um
feel deep down inside rather you know
you should be with this person or not
and realize that love is not just a
feeling you know it might be more than
that
just final thoughts
um final thoughts on divorce
um really think about the ramification
that happens when you do get a divorce
knowing that it doesn't just affect you
and the other person that's in divorce
if you have kids it affects them more
than you may know and if you have
families that are connected it affects
them so really think about it and just
go through
everything whether you gotta go to
therapy something before you take that
drastic leap into the tearing
Two Worlds Apart
um yeah final thoughts on divorce yes
but hey if you didn't get the prenup
beforehand and your lives kind of peek
off to us but I actually said think
about the choices that you make because
again marriage is something that's
supposed to be long term and if you
yourself don't think you can handle the
source there's no way you can handle a
long saw yeah just think about what you
do in life before you make make them
choices cool
um before I before I round up um I just
like to say everyone go and follow Sarah
Garvey on YouTube right now this man do
a hundred get me to 100K 120k okay 120k
and then we can start thinking about
Pals numbers like 700 I mean
um
oh my God what are you gonna do to
celebrate 100K what would I do I don't
know I have to think about that 24 hours
24 hour live streams
[Laughter]
you're gonna be with me okay cool
um but yeah everyone will follow me and
um as like we just said
um
if you have watched tell them two or
more of our videos and you have not
subscribed then we have what beef what
do we have B exactly over to you Bill
you close it out okay a couple
um
more Super Chat so we're just um asked
at the end okay so
um King beats how much for the guy in
the middle to hush
um big boy
um Pearl are you into Mexican guys
you're fine
is fine I'm just saying I don't
discriminate
um okay
um a couple announcements before we end
the show one is that we have two clips
channels the first is just pearly clips
and the second is Pearl daily make sure
you go subscribe to both also go sign up
for our four membership tiers they
really help support the channel and new
equipment upgrades like blessings
monopod yeah the first
um five dollar chat you get to be a part
of our live chat second you get to be a
part of our Discord and blogs third you
get to connect with me on social media
and the fourth you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month
um I help people growing social media or
do a live show so if you have questions
about starting your own live show I
would sign up to that
follow my Instagram I took away my first
one just pearly things one I'd like to
get to 10K I was at 80 is really sad but
I'd like to get you could do 10K no
problem easy easily so go follow my
Instagram
um also if you want to come on the show
um DM the pregame show page um it's on
my Instagram bio I also should be in the
description
um Amiri runs that page so he helps us
get girls for the show that's right so
so it's not get me off the set if you
get me I'm in the background which is my
point which is my point no man hell no
employees people she puts put money in
people's pockets she's a good woman come
on come right please bro yes like
understand what I'm trying to say that's
why if you don't know who they are
that's your problem stay off the
internet we're on the internet we're
gonna head to stay
period
go follow just pearly things um dot five
and six on Tick Tock
um I'm on I'm afraid they're gonna take
my fifth so make sure you go follow my
six two
um and thank you for the super chats
today follow wife school as well we're
going to be dropping a video sometime
this month and we'll